Hi John! Good morning! It's Brotherhood 2.0
with Hank and John Green!
Wow, that guy was having fun. It's seven o'clock
in the morning and I'm about to get on a plane.
Yesterday I was sledding down a hill at Lake
Tahoe. That was fun; this isn't fun.
I hope you don't mind if I make a suggestion
as to how to begin our conversation on this
video blog. Being your brother is kinda frustrating
sometimes. This is because people walk up
to me and they say, "Gosh, you look so much
like your brother. Oh, your jokes are very
similar to your brother's, except you're not
quite as funny as him." Apparently some people
even think that we look like the twin rock
duo, The Proclaimers, which is admittedly
better than people thinking that we look like
the twin rock duo, Nelson.
So, I would like to propose a list. We make
a video blog list of all the ways in which
we are very, very different people.
Things like: in the last few years John Green
has gotten kind of pudgy. Whereas, in the
next few years Hank Green will get kind of
pudgy. And also things like: John Green has
never spilled a tiny amount of beer on his
wife's MacBook, which then proceeded to not
boot up. And also, John Green didn't almost
ruin the video blog experiment by not having
a computer that would work. And also, John
Green didn't do the Happy Dance when his wife
was in the shower, and he reinstalled the
battery and tried to boot it up the next morning
and it worked. (dances) And also, John Green
probably would have told his wife about the
incident instead of hoping everything would
turn out okay. Sorry honey!
And also, and also, and also. And also John
Green doesn't constantly and vainly obsess
about his hair, which apparently I do. On
some level, performing a version of 500 Miles
on this show actually does appeal to me. Punishment,
project, or challenge?